or 2023
goes to
Justin Trier
for only the third time in 76 years a
female director takes Khan's top prize
Justine priet won the jury over with her
tense courtroom drama about a writer
accused of her husband's murder but the
French director used her big moment to
deliver a stinging criticism of
President Emmanuel mcconn's
controversial pension reforms
this year the country was gripped by a
historic extremely powerful and
unanimous protest against the pension
reform
this protest has been denied and
repressed in a shocking way and this
pattern of dominating power of unabashed
power is bursting out across several
spheres
and pries film didn't just snag the top
human prize and one of the fiercest
contests of the Festival International
critics awarded the Palm dog award to
Missy the Palm dog for 2023
goes to
Messi from anatomy of a fool
the Border Collie who played a pivotal
role in anatomy of a fool
the final day of Khan also saw the
festival's other top prizes awarded the
Grand Prix its number two prize Was Won
by Jonathan Glazer's the zone of
Interest an adaption of the life of the
German commandant of the Auschwitz
concentration camp directing honors went
to vietnamese-born French filmmaker Tran
and hung for the portal firm his homage
to French cuisine
the best actor award winter Koji yakusho
who played a working-class Tokyo man in
perfect days
after the screening we were welcomed
with such Applause that it made me feel
like the film has that power to move
people's hearts and motivates his
daughter won best actress for her role
as nurim a rural school teacher in the
Turkish drama about dry grasses it's
hard to be a woman in Turkey but all
over the world new Ray is one of those
women who overcomes life's difficulties
she's a fighter I can't receive this
prize by myself it's thanks to the
strength of all women that I received it
A fitting statement for this year at
Khan the strongest year for women at the
festival since its Inception Alex beard
Al jazeer